table ronde qui est consacrée au retrait
gonflement des sols argileux
vous le savez le phénomène de RGA pose
des défis considérables à notre
politique de prévention et
d'indemnisation sur les plans techniques
les plans juridiques et les plans
financiers
ce risque naturel également appelé
phénomène de sécheresse réhyderatation
des salariés concernent plus
particulièrement
31135 communes
comme une situation en zone d'Alés à
moyen ou d'aller à fort dont 12 000
communes fortement exposées soient plus
d'un tiers de nos communes les régions
Île-de-France
Occitanie Provence Côte d'Azur et
nouvelle Aquitaine sont historiquement
les régions les plus touchées
le RGA se matérialise par l'apparition
de désordre sur les maisons qui peuvent
à terme poser des problèmes de sécurité
et de solliciter du bâtiment en plus de
porter atteinte à la qualité de vie et à
la valeur du patrimoine de nos
concitoyens je pense à des fissurations
sur le gros oeuvre et à des décollements
des affaissements ou des distorsions
d'élement d'éléments de seconde
plusieurs facteurs jouent en la matière
la nature du sol le contraste
hydrogéologique la géomorphologie la
végétation ou encore les défauts de
construction à ces facteurs de
prédisposition s'ajoutent des facteurs
de déclenchement comme les conditions
climatiques d'ailleurs je rappelle que
ce phénomène qui est déjà le deuxième
poste de coût de régime de catastrophe
naturelle derrière les innovations 20
s’accentuer dans les prochaines années
que ce soit d'un point de vue
géographique ou d'un point de vue de la
gravité des dommages causés du fait du
dérèglement climatique qui va poser des
problèmes encore plus substantiels
je note également que la proportion de
dossiers sécheresse dans les demandes
communales de reconnaissance de l'état
de catastrophe naturelle et supérieur de
60% depuis 2017 en outre ses demandes
n'aboutit souvent pas le nombre de
communes non reconnu en état de
catastrophe naturelle pour la sécheresse
s'élever à 30% en 2018 et environ 50%
2019-2020 enfin dans les communes
reconnues environ 50% des dossiers de
sinistre ne sont pas prises en charge
par les assureurs
face à cette situation chacun s'accorde
à dire que le cadre juridique auquel le
traitement des conséquences du RGA qui
s'appuie sur la procédure de
reconnaissance de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle n'est pas satisfaisant en
l'état
compte tenu des effets parfois très
localisés des phénomènes sur quelques
habitations au quartier au sein d'une
commune et de l'absence de prise en
compte de l'importance et de la gravité
et des dommages subis par les habitants
des évolutions sont intervenues ces
dernières années pour mieux après-vender
ce risque pour le futur la loi Elan de
2018 a posé un cadre de prévention pour
les nouvelles constructions qui a été
récemment complétée par une ordonnance
du 29 juillet 2022 visant à renforcer le
contrôle des règles de construction
prise en application de l'article 173 de
la loi du 22 août 2021 dit climat et
résilience
plusieurs décrets d'applications
manquent encore mais le traitement des
problèmes posés au bâtiment actuel déjà
construit n'a pas encore abouti le Sénat
a beaucoup travaillé sur ces sujets et
en particulier notre collègue Nicole
Bonnefoy qui était rapporteur de la
mission commune d'information sur la
gestion des risques climatiques notre
collègue avait notamment recommandé
l'organisation d'une grande campagne
d'information de la population et la
mise en place d'un dispositif
spécifiquement dédié aux risques
sécheresse au sein de fonds de
prévention des risques naturels majeurs
dit font Barnier ce travail avait été
prolongé par le dépôt d'une proposition
de loi adoptée par le Sénat le 15
janvier 2020
puis nous avons de nouveau eu l'occasion
de travailler sur le RGA dans le cadre
de l'examen parlementaire de la loi du
29 décembre 2021 porté par le député
Stephen Beaudu et qui s'est inspirait
largement des travaux du Sénat les
dispositions proposées à l'article 8 par
Pascal Martin remporteur de ce texte au
nom de notre commission et
malheureusement été remplacé par une
simple demande de rapport qui n'a
d'ailleurs toujours pas été remis alors
qu'il aurait dû être transmis par le
gouvernement plus tard pour le 28 juin
2022 enfin je terminerai par ce point
l'article 161 de la loi 3DS du 21
février 2021 2022 habilité le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnance
dans un délai d'un an pour améliorer la
prise en charge des conséquences du RGA
sur le bâti au bénéfice des assurés
sinistrés
récemment enfin notre collègue Christine
lavard de la commission des finances a
mené un travail de contrôle spécifique
sur ce sujet dont nous attendons
impatiemment les conclusions qui à mon
avis seront calés sur la date de
publication de l'ordonnance issue de 3DS
que je viens d'évoquer pour aborder ces
points et tentés d'en apprendre
davantage sur les options de l'étude
dans le cadre de la réforme à venir par
voie d'ordonnance nous recevons ce matin
pour représenter la Fédération française
du bâtiment Monsieur Didier valhem chef
de service à la direction des affaires
techniques monsieur Christophe Boucau
délégué général du pôle habitat
pour représenter France assureur
Monsieur Franck Levallois
directeur général de la Fédération
et pour représenter la direction
générale du Trésor
du ministère de l'économie et des
finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et du numérique monsieur Mayol talon
chef de bureau des marchés et produits
d'assurance je précise à l'intention de
l'ensemble de mes collègues que le
format de cette table ronde a évolué
jusqu'à la dernière minute et que je
n'en suis pas complètement satisfait à
la demande des ministères du pôle
écologie nous avons invité toutes les
administrations compétentes sur ce sujet
qui travaillent en format
interministériel à la préparation de
l'ordonnance qui sera mise prise sur le
fondement de l'article 161 de la loi 3DS
nous avions donc convié la direction
générale de la prévention des risques la
direction générale de l'aménagement du
logement et de la nature la direction
générale de la sécurité civile et de la
gestion de crise et la direction
générale du Trésor certaines
administrations considèrent donc que je
que répondre à une invitation du
Parlement est une option j'en prends
acte et je ferai peur du fond de ma
pensée au ministre des relations avec le
Parlement et au ministre de la
transition écologique nous aurons donc
aujourd'hui le point de vue des
professionnels d'assurance et du
bâtiment et uniquement celui de la
direction générale du Trésor qui devra
nous retranscrire les débats internes au
Gouvernement sur ce sujet
je vais d'ores et déjà passer la parole
à notre collègue Nicole Bonnefoy qui va
vous poser des questions visant à cadrer
nos échanges vous aurez ensuite la
parole pour un propos liminaire d'une
durée de rigueur de 5 minutes qui vous
permettra de répondre aux questions de
notre collègue Nicole Bonnefoy puis nous
aurons une ou plusieurs séquences de
questions réponses je vous remercie et
passe la parole à Nicole Bonnefoy
merci monsieur le Président je prie
d'abord nous inviter d'excuser mon
collègue notre collègue Pascal Martin
sénateur de Seine-Maritime qui a
également travaillé sur ces sujets mais
qui doit assister à une table ronde la
commission des affaires économiques dans
le cadre de l'examen du projet de loi
sur le nucléaire dont il est le
rapporteur pour avis pour notre
commission je souhaitais vous poser
plusieurs questions pour cadrer nos
échanges comme cela vient d'être dit
tout en mes questions vont être à
l'attention plus particulièrement de
Monsieur talon à qui je souhaite la
bienvenue ici au Sénat en regrettant
malgré tout et comme ça a été dit par le
président l'absence de ministères
importants qui sont le ministère de
l'Intérieur et le ministère de
l'écologie donc d'abord des questions
pour Monsieur talon qui représente donc
le gouvernement aujourd'hui pouvez-vous
revenir monsieur talon sur la méthode
d'élaboration de
tendance prévue par l'article 161 de la
loi 3DS quel a été votre calendrier de
travail pouvez-vous rappeler la liste
des services ministériels mobilisés sur
la rédaction de cette ordonnance quelles
ont été les acteurs consultés et
associés à l'élaboration du texte
quelles sont les prochaines étapes de
calendrier pour une publication de
l'ordonnance avant l'expiration du délai
d'habilitation c'est à dire le 21
février prochain
le Conseil d'État a-t-il déjà commencé à
travailler sur le texte en vue de rendre
son avis avant la présentation de
l'ordonnance en conseil des ministres et
pouvez-vous confirmer le dépôt d'un
projet de loi de ratification au
Parlement avant le 21 mai 2023 ensuite
je souhaiterais aborder des questions de
fond qui s'adressent donc à l'ensemble
de nos invités le président lonjo l'a
rappelé chacun s'accorde à dire que la
situation n'est pas satisfaisante dans
son rapport de février 2022 sur le sujet
la Cour des comptes abonde d'ailleurs
dans le même sens mais se refuse à
formuler des propositions législatives
le président l'a également lu dit la loi
élan a permis de mettre en place un
début de politique de prévention en
établissant des règles de construction
et d'attestation dans les zones à risque
mais le cœur du problème quand on aborde
la question du retrait gonflement des
sols argileux et le bâti existant
sachant d'ailleurs que le volume ne
cesse d'augmenter si j'en juge par les
propos tenus par les services
préfectoraux dans mon département ou du
fait de la sécheresse de l'été qui vient
d'avoir lieu les dossiers remontent de
façon très importante donc première
question quel cadre juridique vous
semble chacun pour vos secteurs le plus
pertinent pour traiter la question du
retrait gonflement des solargileux
faut-il rester dans le régime dans le
cadre du régime des catastrophes
naturelles avec quelques modifications à
la marge adaptées à la spécificité de ce
risque ou bien faut-il concevoir un
régime nouveau un régime Haddock
cette question renvoie au point 1 du
Titre 1 de l'article 161 de la loi 3DS
qui porte l'habilitation à légiférée par
ordonnance
point 1 qui dit juridiquement comment
pourrait-on au sein du même régime
catastrophe naturelle introduire une
distinction entre des risques naturels
classiques inondations gouvernement
terrain etc dont l'ampleur et le
caractère anormal serait toujours
apprécié à l'échelle communale et le
risque RGA qui pourrait s'apprécier par
une analyse de la gravité des effets de
ce phénomène à une autre échelle
l'échelle de certains immeubles ou
partie de territoire communal
tout en garantissant une égalité de
traitement à tous les sinistres
par ailleurs le point 1 du Titre 1 de la
méditation allégiféré par ordonnance et
vote le fait de traiter l'indemnisation
des dommages directs
peuvent être ces dommages non assurables
l'objectif de la réforme est-il de
traiter uniquement les dommages les plus
graves et donc les plus coûteux ou bien
de traiter globalement toutes les
conséquences du retrait gonflement des
sols argileux sur les conditions
d'existence des assurés
ensuite comment objectiver l'évaluation
des dommages selon vous avons-nous
besoin de ligne directrice publique de
l'établissement Météo France ou d'un
référentiel spécifique pour les
compagnies d'assurance et les experts
quelle mission afin d'établir un cadre
objectif commun quels sont les débats à
ce sujet dans le cadre de la préparation
de l'ordonnance cette question entre
dans le champ du point 3 du Titre 1 de
l'article 161 de la loi 3DS c'est un
aspect fondamental pour permettre aux
citoyens de comprendre pourquoi ils
peuvent être indemnisés dans tel cas et
pourquoi ils ne peuvent ne pas l'être
dans tel autre cas le travail
d'expertise n'est toujours pas compris
par nos concitoyens d'une manière
générale la transparence est nécessaire
sur cette réforme car le système actuel
pose des questions
d'acceptabilité sociale
le point numéro 2 de la méditation
allégiféré par ordonnance prévoit que le
gouvernement pourra conditionner tout ou
partie du droit à l'indemnisation au
titre du régime catastrophe naturel au
respect de disposition législatives qui
contribue qui contribue à prévoir ou à
couvrir les dommages matériels directs
ayant pour cause le retrait gonflement
des sols argileux cette disposition
m'inquiète car elle pourrait conduire à
refermer fortement le droit à
indemnisation des sinistrés si vous
imposez à tous les propriétaires exposés
au retrait gonflement des sols argileux
de mettre leur maison sur pilotis ou
d'acheter des équipements correcteurs
cela peut représenter un coût très très
important pour rappel la Caisse Centrale
de Réassurance a estimé à 285 milliards
d'euros le coût potentiel des
équipements à installer sur les maisons
actuelles en zone d'aléa fort uniquement
ce qui représente seulement 3,8 millions
de maisons alors que total ce sont près
de 19 millions de maison qui sont
concernés par le retrait gonflement des
sols agiles sur cette question là
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
je poursuis avec une autre question
financière cette fois le fond Barnier
peut-il constituer l'outil de
financement pérenne de ce risque selon
vous faut-il mettre en place un fond
nouveau comment financer les
analysations le budget général de l'État
doit-il davantage être mobilisé j'avais
proposé de prendre appui sur le fond
Barnier mais ces ressources sont
limitées et la soutenabilité du régime
pourrait être menacée à tort j'ai
entendu que la piste relevant des primes
que la piste j'ai entendu que la piste
d'un relèvement des primes au
cotisations additionnelles payées par
les assurés sur le contrat d'assurance
individuel habitat ou père
d'exploitation était étudiée le point 5
du Titre 1 de l'article 161 de la loi
3DS à bord de ce point un habilitant le
gouvernement allégiféré pour
éventuellement adapter le financement de
la garantie contre les catastrophes
naturelles or le gouvernement dit depuis
plus de 5 ans qu'il ne souhaite ni
augmenter les impôts des particuliers ni
leur budget par des mesures qui
s'apparenteraient à une taxation
dissimulée donc je suis un peu perdu
comment allez-vous concilier ces
injonctions contradictoires quelles
proposition avez-vous fait dans le cadre
de la rédaction de l'ordonnance un autre
système de financement reposant sur le
budget général de l'État et une
contribution du secteur assurantiel
a-t-il été envisagé plutôt que de
solliciter les assurer
enfin ma dernière question concerne
l'accompagnement des élus locaux face à
ces problématiques qui me semblent être
un angle mort de cette ordonnance quelle
mesure prévoyez-vous pour accompagner
les élus à la fois en amont dans la
définition de leur stratégie
territoriale en matière d'urbanisation
et en aval dans le traitement des
conséquences du RGA sur leurs
administrés la loi du 28 décembre 2021 a
institué un référent préfectoral à
l'indemnisation des catastrophes
naturelles dont notre commission avait
contribué à étoffer les missions par
voie d'amendement ce référent a-t-il
vocation à intervenir en la matière
selon vous des établissements publics de
l'État spécialisé tels que le cerema
pourrait-il apporter un concours plus
important et gratuit aux élus sur ce
sujet voilà c'est nombre de questions
qui sont
nombreuses mais importantes qui vont
nous permettre d'apprécier la réalité de
engagement de l'État sur un sujet qui
est particulièrement prégnant et dont
certains journalistes récent j'ai
entendu qualifiés de véritables bombes
sociales au regard de l'importance du
nombre des personnes qui sont concernées
par ces sujets et la parole sera ensuite
donnée au collègues qui ont des
questions à poser même si j'en aurai
peut-être encore deux autres concernant
la publication du décret sur la
commission interministérielle qui décrit
qu'il n'est pas encore paru sur la
composition l'organisation de la
commission interministérielle par
exemple merci pour vos réponses
je vous donne la parole
monsieur le Président
Madame la sainte triste Bonnefoy madame
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
alors vous me vous excuserez ce petit
précision qui a un appel certain à la
clémence puisque vous avez remarqué que
je suis le seul représentant de
l'administration aujourd'hui et donc
hélas et donc je ne pourrais
vraisemblablement pas répondre à toutes
vos questions et là c'est également mais
néanmoins je vais m'attacher à répondre
à toutes les questions auxquelles je
suis en mesure de répondre
merci monsieur
je vais commencer vraiment par un propos
très rapide un propos liminaire très
rapide sur la perception de ce problème
par la direction générale du Trésor puis
j'essaie de répondre à vos questions
précises sur sur les travaux menés dans
le cadre de l'ordonnance et après
peut-être si vous êtes d'accord en je
répondrai pas tout de suite à la série
de questions que vous avez énoncé pour
tous les acteurs pour pouvoir se passer
la parole sinon je risque de devoir
parler pendant plus d'une demi-heure et
ça sera désagréable pour chacun d'entre
nous alors concernant la direction
générale du Trésor et de manière
générale pour le gouvernement je pense
que c'est très important de de dire une
chose fondamentale qui est que en France
on a un trésor national on a plusieurs
très grands nationaux mais on a un
trésor national qui n'est pas encore
reconnu au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO mais peut-être qu'il le sera un
jour c'est le régime des catastrophes
naturelles
et aujourd'hui quand on parle du risque
de retrait gonflement des argiles il
faut bien se rendre compte qu'on parle
de ce risque dans le cadre des
catastrophes naturelles on peut aussi
traiter de sujets qui sont à l'extérieur
de ce cadre mais au moins il faut
forcément quand on en discute partir de
ce cadre qui d'ailleurs a été rénové
récemment qui est très efficace et je
pense que si vous le souhaitez on pourra
revenir sur les grands chiffres sur ces
tendances sur sa solidité et je pense
que c'est pas Franck Levallois elle met
côté qui dira le contraire c'est
vraiment un trésor national et quand on
réfléchit sur la sécheresse on est
obligé de s'interroger sur la fiabilité
du régime des 14 naturels et sa
pérennité c'est vraiment un point très
important pour autant on est évidemment
tous autour de la table très conscient
que c'est un sujet qui qui affecte la
vie ne concitoyens tous les jours on est
aussi tous individuellement confrontés à
des personnes qui qui perdent leur
maison qui ont des situations qui sont
souvent terribles et ça c'est un fait et
nous on n'est pas parce que je reprends
aujourd'hui administration à distance
cette réalité les assureurs sont dans la
même situation que que nous le dernier
point c'est que j'espère aujourd'hui
qu'on aura un peu le temps même si c'est
pas ma direction qui en est
particulièrement en charge de pas être
prévention vous l'avez évoqué dans vos
questions ça fait partie aussi des
points qui sont à traiter et qui sont
pas stricto sensu dans le périmètre de
l'ordonnance en tout cas pas totalement
ça c'était vraiment pour faire un tout
petit point d'introduction maintenant
pour pour répondre à vos questions
particulièrement sur l'ordonnance qui
est en cours de rédaction le premier
point c'est de vous dire que
je suis aujourd'hui le seul
représentation reprendra de
l'administration mais néanmoins je suis
contraint de vous dire que aujourd'hui
les arbitrages n'ont pas été rendus par
le cabinet de la Première ministre et
que par conséquent je ne pourrais
aujourd'hui que vous présenter des
données le plus à plat possible pour
vous aider à réfléchir à vous
positionner évidemment prendre votre
avis c'est ses clés mais en aucun le cas
je m'avancerai ni sur la position du
gouvernement ni sur une position qui
serait strictement défendue par la DG
trésor puisque on a un devoir de loyauté
que vous l'imaginez bien en revanche ça
veut dire que que je répondrai pas à vos
questions bien entendu mais je veux
juste quand même vous le dire pour qu'on
soit très clair entre nous sur le
programme de travail vous avez vu donc
l'habitation a été votée dans la loi 3DS
donc à la fin du printemps le la
direction générale du Trésor qui est en
charge du pilotage de ces travaux à
immédiatement mis en place un groupe de
travail avec toutes les administrations
concernées dans un premier temps j'ai
pas la liste sous les yeux mais je peux
vous dire que aucune administration n'a
été oubliée puisque elle était convié le
ministère de l'Intérieur et différentes
composantes du mystère la transition
écologique et des collectivités
territoriales mais également la
direction du budget je perds ne pas t'en
oublier mais en tout cas tous les
ministères étaient associés et nous
avons fait à peu près une dizaine de
rayons de travail qui était découpé à la
fois sur les enjeux juridiques de
des différentes hypothèses sur la table
évidemment des enjeux financiers même
s'il ne faut pas traiter ce sujet
uniquement à travers un angle budgétaire
on est tous d'accord et évidemment avec
une vision plus stratégique sur le
régime des catastrophes naturelles
concernant les professionnels qui ont
été qui ont été associés il est vrai que
il a pas été possible de les associer
comme on l'aurait voulu du fait du
retard qui a été pris sur la prise de
décision du gouvernement puis comme je
vous l'ai dit aujourd'hui la décision
n'a pas été encore prise sur les
paramètres définitifs de l'ordonnance et
donc on ne pouvait pas consulter au-delà
évidemment de questions
générale et technique on n'a pas pu
consulter sur un projet finalisé mais
j'imagine que vous le comprendrez vu les
difficultés que posent ce souci ce
problème pardon concernant les étapes du
calendrier donc ça a été donc ces
groupes de travail une saisine de la
direction d'affaires juridique de Bercy
sur les enjeux juridiques évidemment une
association de la Caisse Centrale de
Réassurance dès le début pour fournir un
maximum de le chiffrage et aujourd'hui
le Conseil d'État pas encore été saisi
puisque le texte n'est pas finalisé il
devrait l'être au début du mois de
janvier plus tard à la au milieu du mois
de janvier pour un examen et donc une
publication à l'ordonnance dans les
délais qui sont impartis par
l'habilitation et évidemment un projet
de loi dans les deux mois qui suivent la
publication ordonnance comme c'est
toujours coutume de le faire
y a-t-il de complément de questions
je vais peut-être vous passer la parole
peut-être passer la parole en
représentant des assureurs pour quelques
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
vice-présidente mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie pour
l'organisation de cette de cette table
ronde sur le thème des risques liés au
phénomène de retrait gonflement des
argiles
et j'essaierai de porter la voix des
assureurs en tant que directeur général
de France assureur c'est-à-dire la
fédération qui rassemble aujourd'hui 247
entreprises d'assurance et de
réassurance relevant du Code des
Assurances soit 99% du marché face à ce
péril qu'elle a sécheresse les assureurs
sont aux côtés des sinistrés le
phénomène de retrait gonflement des sols
argileux liés à les alternance des
épisodes de pluie de sécheresse
conduit à
des situations parfois dramatiques les
seuls argileux composent aujourd'hui une
grande partie de notre territoire
national 48% de notre territoire est en
zone d'exposition forte et moyenne et
ces territoires regroupent 54% des
maisons individuelles bâties en France
cette situation peut conduire à des
moments critiques voire à des drames
pour nos concitoyens
le régime 4 natz est un système
d'assurance mixte qui associe les
entreprises d'assurance et les pouvoirs
publics ce partenariat public privé
et bâti sur deux principes universalité
la solidarité et il garantit aux
particuliers entreprises et
collectivités une indemnisation des
dommages matériels directs causés par un
phénomène naturel dont la sécheresse ce
régime protège il protège les Français
contre les risques de catastrophes
naturelles pour une somme relativement
modique
le financement de ce régime est assuré
par une prime dont le taux est identique
sur l'ensemble du territoire preuve de
la solidarité de ce régime
et le montant de la cotisation
représente en moyenne parfois et 25
euros par an
dans ce régime très encadré les
assureurs sont aux côtés des sinistrés
en les accompagnant dans le processus
d'indemnisation des sinistres
sécheresses et il joue pleinement leur
rôle laissez-moi vous donner quelques
chiffres depuis que la sécheresse est
reconnue dans le régime de catastrophes
naturelles en 1904 dès 1989 les
assureurs ont géré chaque année en
moyenne près de 30000 nouveaux sinistres
liés à la sécheresse pour un montant
cumulé depuis cette période de 16
milliards d'euros cela représente 17% de
la sinistralité climatique c'est-à-dire
l'ensemble des sinistres liés aux
inondations aux tempêtes à la grêle au
vague de submersion poids de la neige et
risque sur récolte notamment
cependant le dérèglement climatique
comme vous l'avez souligné monsieur le
Président
accentue le phénomène et le coût de la
sécheresse ne cesse d'augmenter depuis
1989 la sécheresse représente une par
croissante de la sinistralité climatique
sur la période 89 2015 la sécheresse
représentait 15 % de la sinistralité
climatique sur les cinq dernières années
ces 24%
. l'année 2022 illustre parfaitement
cette tendance sur les cinq dernières
années la sécheresse coûtait en moyenne
par an 950 millions d'euros pour l'année
et la seule année 2022 nous estimons le
coût de la sécheresse entre 1 milliard 9
et 2 milliards 8
et selon toute vraisemblance 2022 battra
le triste record de l'année 2003 avec la
canicule dont tout le monde se rappelle
et qui avait engendré à l'époque deux
milliards centres de sinistres sur les
bâtiments
et la tendance devrait accélérer
elle devrait accélérer France assureur à
réaliser une étude concernant l'impact
du changement climatique sur l'assurance
à l'horizon 2050 deux choses à retenir
de cette étude que nous tenons
évidemment à votre disposition le coût
des sinistres climatiques sur les 30
prochaines années doublera par rapport
au 30 précédentes années
et pour la sécheresse ce ne sera pas un
doublement ce sera un triplement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle les
assureurs sont mobilisés auprès des
pouvoirs publics pour pérenniser le
régime de catastrophes naturelles et le
renforcer
le phénomène de retrait gonflement des
argiles fait l'objet depuis maintenant
quelques temps de réflexion et de
travaux
je saisis l'opportunité aujourd'hui qui
est de dénoncer deux fausses bonnes
idées
deux fausses bonnes idées que je veux
nommer car elle se ferait au détriment
des assurés et de nos concitoyens la
première fausse bonne idée ce serait de
sortir la sécheresse du régime 4 nattes
la deuxième fausse bonne idée serait de
supprimer la réalité de catastrophe
naturelle pour la sécheresse ou à tout
le moins de le vider de sa substance je
pourrais répondre à vos questions et
notamment pour détailler les raisons qui
amènent les assureurs à penser qu'il
s'agit là de deux fausses bonnes idées
il y a en revanche des pistes qui sont
intéressants que je ne vais pas
détailler évidemment mais je pourrais
répondre à vos questions 6 pistes la
première
6 piste pour renforcer le régime de
catastrophes naturelles et notamment sur
les aspects de sécheresse première piste
maintenir l'indemnisation du retrait
gonflement des argiles dans le régime de
4 nattes cela ne vous étonnera pas
deuxième piste préserver l'arrêté de
catastrophe naturelle pour la sécheresse
non plus vous ne serez pas étonné
troisième piste ne pas introduire de
critères de gravité comme la loi 3DS le
permettrait
quatrième piste conditionner
l'indemnisation du sinistre
à la réparation effective des dommages
générés par la sécheresse
cinquième piste développer la
connaissance du risque de sécheresse et
les expérimentations en matière de
prévention et dernière piste déployée
une stratégie nationale de prévention du
risque de sécheresse seul le régime en
cours qui a été établi sur la base d'un
partenariat public privé efficace bâti
en convoquant la solidarité et
l'universalité seul ce régime peut
maintenir une mutualisation des risques
pour un tarif limité pour nos
concitoyens les assureurs ont conscience
que le régime doit évoluer et son
mobilisés pour améliorer la situation
existante et renforcer la résilience de
toute la société je vous remercie
merci j'ai donné la parole à Fédération
française du bâtiment oui merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs
de France assureur simplement revenir
sur
ce que vous avez évoqué monsieur le
Président sur les mesures de prévention
qui ont été prises sur la construction
neuve depuis les loiselans
force est de constater aujourd'hui que
nos adhérents constructeurs aménageurs
et et promoteur
ce sont
mobilisés autour de ces mesures
et que celle-ci
vont et sont de nature effectivement
mieux appréhender le risque argile à
toutes les étapes d'un projet de
construction tant à la vente du terrain
qui a la construction elle-même
ceci peut-être doit nous inspirer pour
inclure dans
les informations qui sont transmises aux
acquéreurs et locataires la transmission
d'un état des risques naturels et
technologique pour les biens immobiliers
situés dans les zones argiles puisque
aujourd'hui cet obligation ne
n'est pas effective dans ces dans ces
zones donc en termes de prévention et
d'information peut-être que nous aurions
un intérêt à effectivement
élargir le élargir le cadre
vu de la Fédération française du
bâtiment et comme comme nos amis de
France assureurs et pour nous assez
assez essentiel que la sécheresse reste
effectivement dans le régime de la de la
de la catastrophe naturelle c'est un
système mutualisé
et une des fausses bonnes idées serait
de transférer la question de du régime
enfin des sinistres Géa dans le cadre de
la garantie décennale des constructeurs
nous avons aussi quelques quelques
éléments de réflexion ou quelques doutes
sur les critères de gravité qui
pourraient être introduites par la loi
3DS en ce sens que
réparer des sinistres des désordres liés
à la sécheresse on introduit la question
de la solidité de l'ouvrage bien
évidemment mais on introduit également
la possibilité de l'impropriété à
destination qui est une mesure quand
même relativement plus plus difficile à
cerner que la solidité de l'ouvrage
là dessus on considère qu'il faudrait
peut-être
ne pas hésiter à intervenir sur des
sinistres naissants de manière à ce
qu'il ne puisse pas s'aggraver dans le
temps puisque on peut avoir des
sinistres qui
sont sont ne sont pas dans entre
guillemets de nature décennale mais qui
avec le temps pourrait évoluer et on se
dit que c'est quand même dommage de ne
pas de ne pas intervenir dès lors que
c'est sinistre apparaissent pour une
question de de prévention et de
non-agravation des désordres
enfin je vais laisser la parole à Didier
valam sur tout ce qui relève des les
questions de recherche et développement
sur sur les réinterventions sur les
ouvrages
donc
comme l'a dit mon collègue donc l'aspect
du parc du flux de construction et
désormais correctement traité avec
depuis 4 ans beaucoup d'actions qui sont
menées depuis la langue dans les
référentiels de construction dans les
aspects contrôles
lorsqu'on parle de donc sur le pacte
existant en effet c'est là où doit être
mené la grosse action donc la difficulté
en effet c'est le diagnostic sur ce
sujet mais qu'on parle de diagnostic il
faut différencier deux aspects c'est à
dire qu'il y a d'une part l'aspect
prévention c'est-à-dire en amont du
sinistre pouvoir allaiter les travaux
qui vont sécuriser mon bâti lorsque je
suis en zone très argileuse donc ça
c'est des dispositions où là on est les
dispositions techniques existent elles
sont partagées dans l'arrêter sur le
neuf donc elles peuvent être facilement
déclinés sur sur l'existant en
prévention après dès qu'on arrive sur
sur la sinistré donc en effet la
difficulté c'est dans un premier temps
le diagnostic et ce diagnostic contenu
de la sensibilité du sujet de prendre un
certain temps d'une nécessité des études
assez poussées
et ensuite adapter les les réparations
donc les réparations qui vont suivant la
gravité des ordres concernés
de la capacité portante de l'ouvrage et
traiter les ouvrages complémentaires en
laissant le temps et non seulement de
mettre en oeuvre de réaliser des
diagnostic de mettre en œuvre les
travaux de confortation mais de saturer
que cette confrontation sont pérennes
donc souvent il faut considérer une
période un cycle saisonnier pour
s'assurer que les réparations
structurées sont efficientes avant
d'envisager les travaux complémentaires
de traitement des fissures secondaires
donc ce sujet étant posé
au niveau des des traitements techniques
donc il y a les guides qui ont réalisé
maintenant se faire bientôt 10 ans qui
apporte des éléments très concrets sur
le diagnostic et sur les éléments de la
passion
et les aspects expérimentations en effet
le retour d'expérience est très
important sur tous les sujets donc
beaucoup d'études sur l'impact de la
végétation la taille des arbres donc le
traitement par des écrans-théracine
l'anticipation
des entretien sur les réseaux sur les
drainage et autres et certains possédés
expérimentaux donc on parle souvent du
procès des Mac qui qui porte sur la
maîtrise de l'humidité du sol de manière
à éviter la respiration ou le cycle
saisonnier donc est un élément
prometteur
à développer et c'est vrai que pour les
entreprises de construction
qu'interviennent donc l'aspect
diagnostic est très important puisque
pour pouvoir intervenir il faut avoir le
bon diagnostic pour les éléments travaux
parce que sinon après l'entreprise qui
intervient elle risque d'exposer en cas
de sinistre de seconde génération et
donc d'expérimentation elle est
importante elle a menée la difficulté
c'est en effet c'est les procédures
accélération lorsqu'on les intervient
sur un ouvrage elle doit assurer quoi
elle doit être assurée pour la
techniquement en oeuvre et que si c'est
des techniques instrumentales à ce
moment les procédés sont un peu plus
difficiles il faut passer par des
interprétations avec lamentation qui
sont parfois lourdes et prennent du
temps donc il y a sûrement une réflexion
à mener sur comment mener des actions de
recherche collective de manière à avoir
un Rex partagé permettant de d'établir
des de mettre au point des dispositifs
d'intervention et de réparation qui soit
les plus économiques possible donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a l'évolution avec les
résines qui ont permis quand même dans
certains cas de s'affranchir des
micro-eux qui sont très coûteux ces
résines donc maintenant elles sont
traitées par des avis techniques donc la
technique est partagée reconnue entre
les professionnels et les assureurs
c'est vrai que il y a sûrement une
réflexion à mener pour aller plus en
avance sur des expérimentations sur les
trottoirs périphériques les écrans
iracine et puis partagez les solutions
innovantes comme le procédé max
merci moi je crois qu'il est sur sur ce
sujet
Nicole on dirait un peu plus mais sur ce
sujet dont nous y travaillons depuis
plusieurs années Nicole Bonnefoy depuis
plusieurs années plus de 30000 communes
sont quand même concernées sur les 35000
que compte notre territoire national
lorsque vous êtes
sur le terrain et que vous rencontrez
des citoyens qui ont effectivement des
maisons dans lesquelles ils ont un mail
à rentrer parce que la porte ouvre plus
et puis parce que tout est fissuré
partout alors effectivement Monsieur le
Représentant des assurances il y a dans
ma commune au moins au moins une
personne qui a qui est totalement
indemnisée c'est enfin qui est prise en
charge c'est 240 000 euros
c'est la construction d'une maison quand
même les quelques travaux si je peux me
permettre de dire quelques travaux donc
je pense que c'est vraiment un sujet et
je crois qu'il faut que le gouvernement
en prennent véritablement conscience
parce que si demain on a un gros
problème un gros pépin ce qui peut
arriver sur ce sujet
personne ne pourra dire bah c'est pas
grave parce que je ne savais pas
aujourd'hui on sait il y a des gros
problèmes on sait très bien que et bien
le problème climatique
va pas s'arranger j'espère être
contredit rapidement mais je suis pas
sûr que ça va s'arranger dans les délais
très courts donc il faut vraiment qu'on
puisse prendre en compte cette
problématique qui était à la fois une
problématique sécuritaire une
problématique financière une
problématique c'est quand même
l'habitation des années
des années de travail des années pour
nos concitoyens c'est leur bien et donc
je pense qu'il y a vraiment une prise de
conscience qu'il faut avoir sur ce sur
ce sujet pour que et bien on puisse
accompagner nos concitoyens qui se
trouvent dans des situations parfois
très très très compliqué mais pour
l'avoir vécu pas chez moi mais les
personnes que je connais bien sur ma
commune à Ornans je peux vous dire que
c'est traumatisant
c'est traumatisant et donc c'est
effectivement quand on vous dit oui j'ai
reçu quelques mots d'ailleurs de gens
qui
et notamment
une association défense du consommateur
qui m'a un petit peu d'ailleurs
attaquer sur le sujet en me disant ce
que je leur ai pensé c'est ce qu'on a
voulu faire mais pour l'instant il y a
rien de concret je sais pas quoi lui
dire derrière parce que effectivement on
a fait des choses mais concrètement il
sait pas complètement abouti alors après
effectivement il y a aussi une contrat
d'assurance avec des contrats
d'assurance qui prévoient ceci ou qui
prévoit pas cela ça c'est ça c'est un
autre débat mais je pense quand on est
alerté souvent sur ces sujets avec des
gens et là ce dont je vous parle ce sont
des gens
vraiment des gens on a certaine âge et
qui sont complètement démunis parce que
ils vont céder en héritage
une Baptiste qui ressemble à tout sur
une bâtisse quoi voilà Nicole
oui je pourrais rajouter que je suis
assez déçue de cette table ronde ce
matin pourquoi parce que le Sénat
travaillait sur ce sujet dans le cadre
d'une mission d'information c'était en
2019 le rapport que nous avons rendu
avec mon collègue Michel vapard
faisait état d'une situation sur la
problématique de très gonflement des sur
l'argileux très délicate et expliquer
que bien évidemment
au regard du réchauffement climatique
cette situation allait empirer nous
faisions à l'époque nombre de constats
et de propositions
ce rapport s'est traduit ensuite par une
proposition de loi qui a été ici votée
au Sénat et qui faisait dans le cadre de
la prévention mais aussi dans le cadre
de l'indemnisation et plus
particulièrement sur la question du
retrait gonflement des solargileux
nombre de propositions
le gouvernement est resté sourd à cette
proposition de loi même si ça s'était en
2020 en 2021 une proposition de loi
celle du député bodu et arriver au
Parlement pour discussion la
problématique est et donc a été votée
que cette proposition de loi là
n'est toujours pas appliqué puisque le
décret d'application qu'il a concernent
ne sont toujours pas publiés quant à la
loi 3DS qui est elle a été votée en
février 2022 avec cette habilitation à
légiférée par ordonnance concernée en
plus particulièrement le roté gonflement
des solargileux avec une date qui expire
prochainement c'est le 21 janvier c'est
ça 2023
pardon février 21 janvier février pardon
2023 on s'aperçoit et vous le avez dit
Monsieur talon que les arbitrages
toujours pas été rendus que des certes
des réunions eu lieu ceci dit je
m'interroge sur vous avez dit qu'il y
avait été entendu une dizaine de
réunions mais à priori les assureurs ne
l'ont pas été
le bâtiment non plus alors qu'il me
semble que les plus concernés sont là et
auraient pu être associé aux travaux du
gouvernement pour enfin apporter des
réponses sur cette problématique c'est
que des retraits gonflements des sols
argileux qui
comme vous le savez et sont extrêmement
prégnants et ça vient encore d'être
rappelé chacun dans nos départements ces
problèmes remontent et remonteront
encore davantage
par dans l'avenir donc je suis
extrêmement déçu à la fois pour par le
manque de représentation des de l'État
et par même si vous avez monsieur talon
apporter quelques réponses vous avez été
loin d'apporter toutes les réponses aux
questions que j'ai posées qui étaient
pourtant preignante vous y venez
maintenant c'est ça d'accord
à ce que fixé le l'ordonnance donc
j'espère que maintenant vous pourrez
apporter alors un peu plus de précision
en tout cas je vais essayer madame la
sénatrice bonne foi bien sûr je vous
avais dit que je répondais pas à vos six
questions tout de suite puisque sinon ça
me paraissait un petit peu long pour
faire le premier tour de table mais il
est bien sûr que je vais essayer d'y
répondre on est bien d'accord monsieur
le Président Longeot vous preniez
l'exemple tout à l'heure de de retraités
qui voyait leur maison fissurée donc le
travail d'une vie se réduire devant eux
il faut aussi penser aux jeunes qui
empruntent qui s'endettent et qui se
retrouvent une maison qui est
inhabitable mais c'est la même chose la
situation à la critique et ne croyez pas
que le gouvernement est sourd à cette
situation
je vais essayer de répondre à vos
différentes questions j'en ai noté 6
n'hésitez pas à me dire si si j'en ai
oublié pressez moi aussi est-ce que vous
voulez que j'essaie de répondre à ces
six questions ou alors je fais une
question on tourne comme vous le
souhaitez alors ces 6 questions la
première c'est quel est le cadre
juridique le plus le plus pertinent pour
essayer de traiter au maximum cette
question Franck Levallois a déjà dit
tout à l'heure et je l'ai dit en
introduction pour nous le cadre
juridique le plus pertinent c'est le
cadre du régime des catastrophes
naturelles il y a plusieurs points à
relever là dessus et donc la question
est-ce qu'il faut faut-il un régime
nouveau
elle est complexe parce que on ne peut
pas dire que le régime des 14 naturelles
pourra traiter l'ensemble de la question
je vais revenir mais en revanche est-ce
qu'il faut
en sortir ou le faire exploser la
réponse est clairement non en revanche
on a des propositions pour le faire
évoluer afin d'indemniser davantage de
sinistrer je vais y revenir encore une
fois mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
rester dans ce régime des catastrophes
naturelles je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
que c'était un trésor national on sait
pas une un 20 mot je pense que Franck je
suis partage cette idée c'est vraiment
un mode
d'indemnisation de ces catastrophes
exceptionnelles qui est à la fois
extrêmement robuste très efficace et qui
aujourd'hui est pris en exemple dans
plusieurs cas à l'étranger par son mode
de fonctionnement son mode de
fonctionnement vous les avez tous c'est
des surprises obligatoires sur contrat
d'assurance
qui sont pas stricto strictement parler
des des prélèvements obligatoires mais
qui s'en rapprochent et qui finance à la
fois
l'indemnisation fournit par la sueur et
à la fois la protection qu'apporte la
réassurance publique à travers la Caisse
Centrale de Réassurance sous forme de et
donc de garantie illimitée de l'État en
cas de perte exceptionnelle pour le
régime et donc qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire concrètement il y a
une solidarité entre la France des
campagnes et la France des villes entre
la France d'outre-mer et la France
métropolitaine et que ce régime il est
fondamental qu'il ne faut pas le perdre
puisque si nous le perdions nous le
perdrions pour les inondations pour les
ouragans aux Antilles etc en outre-mer
et ça ça serait vraiment une catastrophe
et donc pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
garder ce cadre de régime des
catastrophes naturelles en l'adaptant
c'est parce que aujourd'hui il indemnise
de selon les termes que tu as utilisé
les chiffres que tu as utilisés en poids
et revenir déjà un très grand nombre de
personnes même si on est conscient que
ce n'est pas suffisant et ça on pense
qu'il ne faut pas le perdre
un régime nouveau ça peut s'étudier on
va revenir sur sur votre deuxième
question sur les dommages les plus
graves mais on va essayer de vous dire
pourquoi est-ce que nous on pense que si
on quittait le cas des catastrophes
naturelles une reconnaissance par un
arrêté intermédiaire et une commission
d'une catastrophe naturelle et si on
passait par exemple un régime simplement
basé sur l'exception de la gravité sur
les conséquences du bâti ce que laisse
c'est la possibilité que laisse le
deuxièmement de cette habilitation on
pense qu'il y a plusieurs problèmes vous
allez mentionner tout à l'heure le
nombre de maisons qui sont concernés par
le risque argileux si mes chiffres sont
bons il s'agit de 10 millions sur 19,5
millions d'habitations en France donc
c'est la moitié des maisons en France
mais si je me trompe pas il y a 19,5
millions d'habitations individuelles en
France et il y en a 10 millions qui sont
situés sur le sol argile donc une maison
sur deux pour être très concret c'est
c'est concrètement très très important
mais c'est vraiment du potentiel
effectivement c'est pas des maisons
sinistrées on est bien d'accord
la deuxième chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui
dans le dans le régime des catastrophes
naturelles on a un milliard d'euros qui
sont consacrés à la sécheresse par an
alors que il y a 10 ans c'était 500
millions d'euros par an donc on voit
bien que le que le régime déjà mais
surtout il y a une accélération
dans ce régime aujourd'hui
80% de l'indemnisation et concentrée sur
20% des sinistres les plus graves
donc aujourd'hui si on pourrait répondre
à votre deuxième question si on passait
à une logique que nous permet cette
habilitation on est d'accord
de quitter le constat d'avoir un
événement météorologique d'une
exceptionnelle gravité a simplement une
exceptionnelle gravité des conséquences
sur le bâti à notre sens ça présenterait
plusieurs dangers le premier danger
c'est que le régime des catastrophes
naturelles qui est déjà très sollicité
on en revient on y reviendra quand on
parlera dans votre troisième question de
la question de relèvement des surprises
le régime qui est déjà très tendu
aujourd'hui serait un absence
insoutenable
deuxièmement si nous quittons le
l'arrêter le format d'un arrêté
interministériel ça veut dire que l'État
n'aurait plus aucun thermostat pour
régler et gérer cette c'est une
organisation et du coup être un
régulateur du système et ça veut dire
aussi que le caractère d'exceptionnel
gravité ne serait apprécié que par les
experts
et à notre sens même si j'y reviendrai
également dans les pistes de travail
actuels il y a le renforcement de
l'exigence qui va être adressé aux
experts dans ce contexte particulier on
pense qu'aujourd'hui si on ne faisait
reporter cette cette charge que sur les
experts ça nous donnerait un système qui
est incomplet et donc pour toute ces
raisons et je pense que je peux je peux
me permettre de développer ce point ici
aujourd'hui
en tout cas pour la direction générale
du Trésor l'hypothèse principale que
l'on favoriserait ça ne se serait de ne
pas utiliser la possibilité de faire
cette révolution copernicienne celle de
quitter le régime des catastrophes
naturelles pour entrer simplement sur un
caractère d'exceptionnel gravité mais à
l'inverse
de détendre certains critères du régime
actuel notamment sur les reconnaissances
géologiques et météorologiques afin
d'analyser davantage à la fois de
reconnaître plus de communes
typiquement d'avoir un réflexion sur les
communes limitrophes parce qu'on a tous
en tête cette situation ou une personne
a pu être indemnisée et en face de chez
lui dans la même rue parce qu'ils ont
une autre commune une personne n'a pas
pu être indemnisée parce qu'il y a pas
eu d'arrêter 4 nattes on peut on
travaille aussi sur les solutions là
dessus et après de trouver un régime
d'exclusion donc ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure notamment exclure les tous les
tous les constructions qui ont été qui
sont postes ou à élan en fait ce qui est
en fait un peu naturel puisque ces
constructions n'ont pas vocations au vu
de les exigences de fondation à être
indemnisés par la sécheresse puisque si
elles ont bien été construite ils
devraient pas de problème et on pourra
revenir évidemment sur les enjeux des
dommages esthétiques ou sur des éléments
non structurels pour permettre justement
d'indemniser plus
tout en rendant ce régime toujours aussi
viable et de ne pas se trouver dans une
situation le régime serait insoutenable
puisqu'en fait si le régime devenait
insoutenable au fond on ne perdrait bien
plus que simplement une difficulté à
indemniser la sécheresse qu'un point le
point qui nous rassemble mais ce sera
pas vrai notre capacité indemniser
toutes les catastrophes naturelles en
France métropolitaine et outre-mer et
c'est pour nous vraiment une priorité
est-ce que vous voulez je continue sur
vos questions alors troisième question
si j'ai bien noté c'est le rôle du fond
Barnier l'articulation avec le budget
général de l'État et le relèvement
déprime alors effectivement je regrette
que nos camarades d'autres ministères
soient pas là parce que je suis pas un
expert du fond Barnier je peux pas je
sais pas le mieux placé pour vous vous
répondre la question de l'intervention
du budget général de l'État elle est
très importante
et toutefois vous vous imaginez bien que
c'est toujours très difficile d'imaginer
ces modalités puisque si on fait
intervenir l'objet général de l'État
au-delà de l'importance pour les
finances publiques donc il y a un choix
politique qui relève de du Parlement il
y a tout l'enjeu de l'expertise du
contrôle des seuils qui seraient
retenues puisqu'on pourrait pas dire par
exemple toutes les maisons qui sont
fissurées sans nécessairement être
l'objet d'un risque argileux ni du d'un
phénomène météorologique exceptionnel
auront droit à une indemnisation qui
soit budgétaire ou sous forme d'aide
fiscale il y aura nécessairement un
travail qui serait très important sur le
contrôle et sur les caractéristiques
d'éligibilité donc c'est pas à moi de
répondre à cette question mais en tout
cas il est certain que les travaux sur
ce sujet serait nécessairement très
complexe en tout cas devrait être mené
en collaboration toutes les parties
prenantes mais c'est pas une question
qui est évidente sur le relèvement des
primes vous l'avez dit très justement le
gouvernement depuis cinq ans a annoncé
comme priorité le fait de ne pas croître
la pression fiscale mais au contraire de
la réduire et
cette priorité elle est encore plus
renforcée dans une situation
exceptionnelle l'inflation donc pourquoi
est-ce que on a ces réflexions
aujourd'hui c'est que on ne peut pas
traiter la sécheresse sous un angle
uniquement budgétaire ce n'est pas
acceptable ni socialement ni
politiquement et comme je vous dis pour
un autre côté en même temps on est
obligé d'avoir en tête la soutenabilité
du régime des catastrophes naturelles et
aujourd'hui la surprime d'assurance qui
est établi à 12% de tous les contrats
hormis les contrats auto qui sont à 6%
si je me trompe pas aujourd'hui cette
surprise elle sera vraisemblablement
sollicité
en régime de croisière même si on ne
fait rien de plus sur la sécheresse
aujourd'hui la tendance de renforcement
des aléas climatiques impliquera
vraisemblablement une hausse cette
surprise horizon 5 ans c'est inévitable
et pour autant effectivement aujourd'hui
la priorité du gouvernement c'est
d'essayer de trouver toutes les
solutions possibles pour ne pas se
retrouver à se dire d'un doublon à
surprime parce qu'on peut dire 25 euros
pour un foyer c'est pas beaucoup ben
c'est 50 euros c'est beaucoup mine de
rien et on peut pas simplement se dire
d'où l'on a surpris mais et on peut
faire ce qu'on veut donc nous on est
très gentil au fait que en régime de
croisière le régime des catastrophes
naturelles il imposera à terme un
ajustement sur la surprise et donc on
doit avoir en tête que le traitement du
risque retrait gonflement des argiles il
doit aussi s'inclure dans cette
trajectoire et typiquement si selon les
estimations que camenet la CCR si on
reprenait pour revenir sur le deuxième
question uniquement le critère des
dommages les plus graves sans retenir
par exemple à la fois de hausse des
Francis de franchise sans retenir de
seuil d'intervention c'est-à-dire par
exemple de se dire un dommage grave
est-ce que c'est 50000 euros si la
maison vaut 50 000 euros de mage grave
il est pas à 50000 euros c'est beaucoup
moins et ne pas prendre de plafond
d'intervention puisque aujourd'hui dans
les régimes des naturels il y a pas de
plafond d'intervention sur votre maison
donc c'est à dire que vous êtes
indemnisés pour la reconstruire telle
qu'elle a tel que cela coûte mais on
vous dit pas voilà le plafond
intervention c'est 90 000 euros si
aujourd'hui on me prend aucun de ces
critères sans traiter le stock on sera à
plus de 500 millions d'euros de sur coup
pour les finances publiques en tout cas
pour CCR mais il finit du coup pour la
garantie limitée de l'État par an et le
stock représente plutôt deux milliard 5
donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui c'est
cette situation elle implique à la fois
de travailler sur ce qui est faisable et
en même temps être bien conscient que
c'est que on ne peut pas tout email on
peut tout imaginer mais on peut pas tout
réaliser puisque si on
prenait par exemple le cas de l'extrême
gravité enfin du dommage les plus graves
mais sans prendre aucun seuil sans aucun
paramètre on aura un système qui serait
dès l'année prochaine insoutenable
les assureurs pour la construction
excusez-moi j'aurais dû vous répondre
tout à l'heure en fait ne croyez pas
qu'on a travaillé dans le vase clos et
qu'on a consulté personne simplement
qu'on n'a pas pu consulter quelqu'un sur
un texte finalisé puisque aujourd'hui il
n'est pas arbitré c'est pas c'est
logique mais en revanche évidemment
qu'on a discussion très très simple je
pense comment on parle même toutes les
semaines franchement tu peux plusieurs
fois tu peux le reconnaître parce que
c'est c'est une de nos priorité tout
simplement c'est un sujet fondamental
au niveau des arbitrages que vous êtes
en train de de faire on pourra être
destinataire des arbitrages pour savoir
un petit peu où vous allez comment ça va
ce qui se passe
bien évidemment bien évidemment c'est
bien sûr sachez donc dans tous les cas
les arbitrages ils vont être pris dans
les jours qui viennent
les jours qui viennent au vu du timing
puisque l'ordonnance doit être publié
avant le 22 février 2023 donc dans tous
les cas les arbitrages ils vont être
pris dans les jours qui viennent et
évidemment vous serez destinataire
merci Monsieur Levallois
alors je peux essayer de répondre à
votre question 5 et 6 mais la question
sur Météo France je ne suis pas sûr je
peux déjà essayer de répondre à vos
questions parce que votre question 4 est
sur les propositions que l'on
retiendrait dans l'ordonnance je les ai
déjà évoqué mais comme on m'a dit on
aujourd'hui la réflexion elle se pose
justement sur l'opportunité de prendre
le deuxième alinéa sur gravité ou pas
vous avez compris que c'est pas la
position la direction générale du Trésor
mais ça ne présage pas de la position
pendant le gouvernement infini bien sûr
et comme je vous l'ai mentionner il y a
la question de l'exclusion de certains
dommages qui sont des signaux très
important sur la loi Elan par exemple
sur la dommage ouvrage donc les 10 ans
sur les dommages esthétiques les
éléments non structurels dont je vous ai
parlé il y a aussi évidemment le point
dans l'ordonnance de mentionner que les
les indemnisations devront être
affectées à la reconstruction comme tu
as mentionné Franck et aussi le
renforcement des experts en RGA donc
l'ordonnance elle sera prise dans tous
les cas l'important c'est les critères
qui seront qui seront retenus votre
cinquième point c'était si je me trompe
pas sur l'accompagnement des élus locaux
alors effectivement le référent qui a
été mis en place par la loi de décembre
2021 aura à mon sens toutes vocation à
répondre à ces questions et il sera
certainement d'ailleurs très sollicité
sur ce point sur votre sixième question
sur la publication des décret qui feront
trois choses à la fois la constitution
de la Commission Internationale
consultative qui associe très largement
les élus mais également sur les
franchises applicables aux particuliers
et aux entreprises et enfin sur les
frais de relogement d'urgence tous les
textes sont prêts sont en consultation
obligatoire d'une part devant le CNN
demain le CCLF de main également et
puisqu'il n'y a pas de saisine
obligatoire du Conseil étal les textes
seront publiés dans la foulée
c'est-à-dire normalement la semaine
prochaine pour évidemment rentrer en
vigueur au 1er janvier 2022 voire de 23
pardon comme c'était prévu
essayons
quelle était votre question sur Météo
France
il y a eu des débats
et ça fait partie de la proposition que
l'on porte aujourd'hui qui est que
aujourd'hui dans le cas la sécheresse il
y a 12 critères qui sont pris en charge
qui sont pris en compte pardon pour
évaluer si une commune est éligible au
régime des quatre nattes et donc au
traitement de la sécheresse à travers
des régimes Cannat et donc il y a d'une
part des des critères qui sont de nature
pour être très précis et les critères
qui sont de nature géothermiques et des
critères qui j'avais pas retrouvé le
point que je voulais mentionner
exactement mais il y a des critères
géothermiques et les critères qui sont
géophysiques et en fait nous notre
proposition c'est de simplifier ces
critères notamment ce qu'on appelle la
durée de retour en fait la période de
calcul du référentiel pour justement
être capable de prendre en charge
davantage de sinistrer d'avoir moins
d'exclusion en fait de communes c'est
augmenter le nombre de communes qui
seront reconnues
dans le cadre
du régime 4 NAT sécheresse pour pouvoir
indemniser plus de sinistre
c'était un aspect fondamental je me
souviens du rapport puisque le nombre de
gens qui sont dans les dossiers sont
rejetés dans le cadre de reconnaissance
n'arrivait pas à comprendre les raisons
de ce rejet donc bien évidemment bien
évidemment le la question de Météo
France avec un référentiel spécifique
une transparence et une communication
des données est essentiel
tout à fait
merci monsieur le Président oui je
souhaitais peut-être
rebondir sur quelques points qui ont été
évoqués et notamment à travers vos
questions madame la vice-présidente je
reviens sur le
premier premier point qui est le cadre
juridique et notamment derrière ce
question du cadre juridique c'est la
sortie
du de la sécheresse du péril sécheresse
du régime catastrophe naturel
comme je vous l'ai dit il nous semble
que la sortie du régime 4 natz serait
une fausse bonne idée et une fausse
bonne idée j'insiste sur un point qui
est celui de la mutualisation
le principe de base de l'assurance et la
mutualisation c'est à dire qu'avec les
cotisations de tous on puisse arriver à
indemniser les sinistres des plus
malchanceux
il se trouve que le régime catastrophe
naturelle et c'était la logique qui a
présidé à la
création de ce régime en 1982 c'était de
pouvoir rendre assurable des risques qui
ne l'était pas qui n'étaient pas assurés
par la seule assurance privée
d'où ce régime de type partenariat
public privé et je confirme les propos
de Mayol talon c'est qu'à l'étranger
lorsque nous évoquons ce sujet des
catastrophes naturelles du réchauffement
climatique et de l'existence de ce
régime en France nos confrères nous
envient et envie ce régime catastrophe
naturel donc il faut aussi voir les
choses lorsque elles sont elles sont
j'allais dire bénéfiques et protectrices
pour nos concitoyens même si évidemment
ce régime nécessite comme tout d'être
modernisé et renforcés
la mutualisation c'est la base et ce
régime organise une mutualisation
à grande échelle puisque c'est une
mutualisation qui s'organise sur
l'ensemble des contrats de type multiris
habitation multipro et aussi automobile
pour les contrats automobiles qui
disposent d'une garantie de dommages et
d'envoyer bien que c'est cette
mutualisation globale qui permet
finalement à une personne qui va habiter
sur une zone argileuse d'être protégée
d'être assuré
grâce finalement cette mutualisation il
y a d'autres personnes qui vont
peut-être vivre dans la l'autre moitié
de notre territoire national qui n'est
pas concerné vraiment véritablement par
des sous-sols argileux
cette mutualisation elle est importante
si on sortait la sécheresse du régime
catastrophe naturel en fait on tuerait
cette mutualisation à grande échelle ce
qu'il adviendrait c'est que finalement
on créerait une garantie ou que sais-je
à part
et les assureurs évidemment
faisant coïncider le niveau de risque
avec le niveau des cotisations et bien
et bien on pourrait voir sur le marché
des des tarifs segmentés et donc des
personnes qui habitent sur des zones
particulièrement exposées et bien
s'assurer pour un coût bien plus élevé
qu'aujourd'hui et peut-être que pour
certains foyers on arriverait à des
coûts qui seraient intenables
et donc on arriverait à de la
non-assurance voilà voilà la raison pour
laquelle la sortie de ce péril du régime
catenat se fait une fausse bonne idée et
ce ferait en défaveur de nos concitoyens
parce que cette sortie tuerait le
principe de mutualisation à grande
échelle
merci est-ce qu'il y a d'autres d'autres
questions d'avoir de nos collègues
sur ce sujet oui
je voudrais
comparer le système français qui qui est
vanté par nos
intervenants avec l'étranger à
l'étranger à ma connaissance le système
des catastrophes naturelles n'existe pas
donc il faut redescendre d'un niveau et
voir quels sont
les sinistres qui sont indemnisés en
France et ceux qui ne le sont pas il y a
deux cas de figure grosso modo il y a la
construction neuve qui est opérée par un
maître d'ouvrage et qui va lui pouvoir
éventuellement c'est c'est ce que
disent les étrangers va pouvoir prévenir
le sinistre c'est-à-dire faire une étude
de sol avoir tous les renseignements
techniques suffisants pour permettre
d'éviter
le retrait gonflement des argiles
c'est la première situation la deuxième
situation qui est la plus souvent celle
qui amène
les sinistres de façon surprenante pour
les acquéreurs l'acquisition d'un
immeuble qui est déjà construit et là en
droit français le système c'est le
système des vices cachés soit le vendeur
a connaissance de l'existence d'une
fragilité du sol et donc il sait que le
vice existe dans sa maison et si
l'acheteur peut prouver qu'il le sait à
ce moment-là
juridiquement on peut lui demander
d'intervenir pour un débrisé par contre
c'est pas toujours facile à faire parce
qu'effectivement si comme je reprends
les ratios qui étaient évoqués tout à
l'heure par notre président
sur 35000 communes françaises il y en a
30 000 qui ont été touchés par des
arrêtés de catastrophes naturelles
effectivement on peut penser que la
quasi-totalité du territoire national
est concernée et là je vois pas comment
avec le système de garantie des vices
cachés on peut obtenir une indemnisation
donc
je pense qu'effectivement et là je
rejoins les orateurs qui sont intervenus
le système actuel est sans doute le
meilleur mais je pense que au moins sur
les maisons qui sont construites
faudrait peut-être améliorer le système
de prévention et de connaissance de la
nature des sols et puis sur les ventes
et bien peut-être serait-il intéressant
de voir à chaque fois qu'on vend une
maison qui construit depuis un certain
temps si il y a déjà eu sur la commune
concernée des situations de catastrophes
catastrophes naturelles et à ce
moment-là effectivement
la situation serait différente pour
l'acquéreur parce qu'il aurait
connaissance de cette il pourrait
peut-être faire des vérifications avant
de passer l'acte de vente
c'est la question que je vous pose et je
demande si tout ça a été
imaginé monsieur le sénateur alors pour
votre deuxième remarque oui
effectivement ça a été imaginé j'aurais
dû le mentionner c'était une des pistes
de l'heure de lance
en revanche c'est vrai que sur le vote
première question
il s'agit peut-être d'une inculture de
ma part mais je n'ai pas connaissance de
situation dans lequel un recours sur le
fondement des vices cachés aurait permis
de de revenir sur sur l'achat d'une
maison et obtenir une indemnité de la
part du vendeur sachant pertinemment que
sa maison était sur une zone de
argileuse d'obtenir de la part du
vendeur du coup une indemnisation pour
pour l'acheteur est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu ce genre de cas parce que
[Musique]
si l'acheteur peut prouver que celui qui
lui a vendu avait connaissance pour une
raison pour une autre par témoignage ou
autre on peut le prouver que le sol
présenté des défauts à ce moment-là je
pense moi que le recours peut-être
exercer mais il y a peut-être pas je
n'ai pas fait de recherche de
jurisprudence j'arrive un peu dans un
dossier que je connais mal mais c'est
une recherche qu'on peut faire il y a
peut-être eu des cas contenu du nombre
de cas qui sont présentés il y a bien
quelqu'un qui a imaginé cette sortie un
jour on va le regarder parce que c'est
un point très intéressant de l'état de
nos connaissances actuelles on avait le
sentiment que les phénomènes de
sécheresse puisqu'ils sont très
progressifs
la rendre très difficile le fait de de
donner avec certitude un fait générateur
alors peut-être nos collègues de la
Fédération pourront nous répondre là
dessus mais pour compléter ce que je dis
mais je crois savoir que on a vraiment
beaucoup de mal à prouver
se fait générateur avec grande précision
et que par conséquent je crois pas qu'on
est de cas reconnu en jurisprudence pas
un mètre temps de voir ses actions qui
seraient je vous l'accorde très fondé
notamment si le vendeur a pertinemment
connaissance de phénomènes passé et qui
permettrait en fait de d'agir en
résolution de la vente mais c'est un
point très intéressant merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le Président oui mais
peut-être en rebond monsieur le sénateur
pas par rapport à votre votre remarque
et votre votre question qui va tirer
dans un sens de plus grand de
transparence peut-être
indiquer ou justifier pourquoi tout à
l'heure
j'ai mentionné parmi les pistes et les
propositions qui pouvaient être
intéressantes et pertinente pour
préserver ce régime catastrophe de
catastrophe naturelle dont je vous
confirme qu'il n'existe pas il y a pas
d'équivalent à l'étranger c'est de
conditionner l'indemnisation du sinistre
à la réparation effective des dommages
générés par la sécheresse qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que en fait
aujourd'hui l'assuré peut librement
disposer de l'indemnité d'assurance qui
lui est versée par l'assureur outil du
régime de catastrophe naturelle cette
indemnité d'assurance lui est versée et
ensuite il peut en faire ce qu'il veut
les réparations donc réparer la maison
ou pas et on constate on a on commence à
avoir des retours
du terrain d'assureur ou d'experts qui
signale des des cas des dossiers dans
lesquels on a des mises en fait deux
fois tout simplement parce que il y a
changement de propriétaire et que
lorsque on a un deuxième arrêté de
catastrophe naturelle et bien le
deuxième propriétaire va déclarer le
même sinistre qui avait été initialement
déclaré et on va repayer une deuxième
fois la raison pour laquelle il nous
semblerait opportun dans ce dans ce
cadre particulier d'un régime euh public
privé c'est de réserver ou de s'assurer
que les les indemnités versées au titre
au titre du régime sont bien affectés
sont bien réservés à la réparation
effective des dommages qui ont été
occasionnés par la sécheresse et ça
permettrait monsieur le sénateur de
répondre en partie bien sûr mais au
point que vous avez soulevé
monsieur le Président
sur la construction neuve ce sénateur
vous vous suggériez de peut-être de
d'aller encore plus loin dans les dans
les mesures de prévention
aujourd'hui la pratique est celle d'une
étude géotechnique de conception donc
qui est qui est normé par par une
armadoc sur laquelle le constructeur va
s'appuyer pour dimensionner les
fondations et dimensionner l'ensemble de
de l'ossature permettant de gérer ses
risques de roderie gonflement d'argile
qui demeure toujours des risques
la carte la carte RGA est
considérablement évolué et il est pas
impossible qu'elle évolue encore à
l'avenir en fonction effectivement des
événements climatiques donc pour pour
nous bien évidemment constructeur on
prend en compte les éléments à
disposition
issus des études géotechniques en
dimensionne effectivement avec le bureau
d'études l'ensemble des fondations pour
réduire l'exposition au risque tel qu'il
est connu aujourd'hui
en cela je veux je voudrais simplement
dire qu'on est aujourd'hui très réservé
à exclure du régime catnat les
constructions
depuis la loi Elan puisque bien
évidemment tout est pris aujourd'hui
tout est dispositions sont prises pour
dimensionner les ouvrages de nature à
répondre au risque mais il est pas
certain que nous n'ayons pas de risque
différents dans un dans un délai de 5 ou
8 ans ce qui fait que dès lors qu'on
aurait un sinistre sur des sur des
maisons qui seraient construites
effectivement avec la dispositions
relevant de la loi Elan
et on a des cas de jurisprudences
aujourd'hui ou le régime 4x4 se retourne
contre la garantie décennales Fall
assura en se retourne contre l'assureur
décennale pour la prise en charge des
réparations donc je pense que c'est
c'est peut-être pas une une en tout cas
pour nous une bonne idée que de que
d'exclure du régime 4 NAT de manière
systématique bien évidemment les
constructions qui sont qui sont
construites depuis la loi
s'agissant du stock je protège je mets
j'étais
pas suffisamment précis dans mon propos
luminaire mais je pense que
l'information effectivement pour les
acheteurs elle est essentielle
pour les les acheteurs bien évidemment
de bien immobilier pour les habiter ou
pour les mettre en location en cela je
voudrais peut-être resugérer la piste de
faire évoluer le dispositif
d'information des acquéreurs des
locataires qui a été pris en application
de l'article 236 de climat résilience
pour inclure dans cet état
l'obligation de donner l'information dès
lors que le bien se situe dans une zone
d'aléa argile forte ou modérée ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et ce qui
permettrait de ce qui permettrait à ces
mêmes acheteurs d'avoir une connaissance
claire effectivement de la situation de
ce bien par rapport à ce risque précis
de de de retrait gonflement en argile et
de prévoir le cas échéant des
investigations supplémentaires sur le
système de fondation permettant le cas
échéant de pouvoir engager des travaux
de
non pas de réparation mais là de
prévention
à l'achat puisque on sait que
généralement c'est dans ces phases là
que l'on a que les ménages engagent les
travaux on achète un bien généralement
en langage des travaux et peut-être que
à partir de ce qui a évoqué au Didier
vallem tout à l'heure sur des travaux de
recherche permettant effectivement
d'intervenir en amont on pourrait
inclure des travaux de de confortation
des fondations pour réduire l'exposition
au risque et donc pour réduire les
sinistrateurs
réel et nous les avons constaté
seulement 21 ont été prises en
considération au titre des victimes de
ce phénomène et ça qu'est-ce que ça a
provoqué ça suscité d'incompréhension
d'abord des élus qui n'avaient pas
d'explication qui n'avaient pas de
réponse et des familles qui étaient
durement impactées des collectifs
d'ailleurs d'usagers se sont créés pour
se battre pour faire reconnaître j'ai
interrogé le préfet qui n'a pas pu me
donner de réponse voilà alors moi je
voudrais vous dire si je crois avoir
compris que la commission
interministérielle est chargée de se
prononcer sur l'intensité anormale de
l'événement à l'origine des dégâts et
non sur l'importance des dégâts
eux-mêmes pour juger de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle je crois avoir
compris ça donc dans ces conditions il
est totalement incompréhensible que des
communes voisines limitrophes ayant la
même situation et les mêmes
caractéristiques des sols
identiques et puis ne pas reconnu elle
en catastrophe naturelle nous les élus
n'avons aucune réponse et la situation
est incompréhensible sur le terrain
c'était ce que disait le rapport et la
loi était justement là pour apporter des
réponses
pour votre témoignage il est très
important et on espère pouvoir y
répondre sachant que strictement parler
on n'a pas forcément besoin une
ordonnance d'une loi pour faire ça
puisqu'en fait les critères de
reconnaissance de la commission internée
mystérielle ils sont fixés par une
circulaire et donc cette circulaire on
peut la faire évoluer et on peut
évidemment communiquer dessus et c'est
le but de la commission que vous avez
que vous avez cité qui qui rentre qui va
bientôt être installé qui va justement
évaluer quand vous avez cité la
commission de reconnaissance mais il y a
aussi la commission congélative que
propositions
tout à fait tout à fait et donc ce qui
est très important c'est effectivement
oui il y a un certainement une trop
faible reconnaissance des communes
touchées et il y a particulièrement le
point du maillage que vous avez vous
avez relevé dans lequel on estime enfin
on est certain de vouloir répondre
puisque effectivement aujourd'hui c'est
pas expliqué pour les citoyens d'avoir
des communes qui sont limitrophes et qui
par conséquent voilà et comme pour
autant y revenir on voit bien que la
Commission est un mystériale n'a pas
vocation à s'appuyer sur la gravité des
conséquences puisque dans ce cas là en
fait elle évaluerait pas le fait qu'il y
ait une catastrophe naturelle mais
simplement c'est conséquences mais on
est bien d'accord effectivement qu'il
faut travailler sur ce maillage
bien merci mon chien vraiment à vous
remercier la Fédération française du
bâtiment merci le représentant des
assureurs à remercier Monsieur talon
merci pour cette pour cette échange et
on a bien vu à travers à travers cet
échange toutes les difficultés qu'il y
avait et l'attente de nos concitoyens
sur ce sur ce sujet j'espère qu'on va
effectivement aboutir rapidement et que
la publication des ordonnances
ne sera pas maintenant plus attendre je
regrette encore une fois mais je
regrette vraiment effectivement que que
certaines administrations n'est pas
voulu se déplacer parce que on sent bien
que ce sujet est un sujet important et
moi je remercie bien Michel passeport
parce que il était aussi avec toi au
départ merci à Nicole Bonnefoy et puis à
Pascal Martin pour pour le grand
engagement sur ce sujet et sachez que
comme bon nombre de sujets
le Sénat et très attaché à
l'aboutissement effectivement des des
dossiers et des propositions qu'ils font
et que sur ce dossier je ne doute pas de
la termination Nicole Bonnefoy pour ne
pas lâcher ce dossier on reste en
campagne
et ben merci